[Music]
we started as a media business and built
up a big group of readers who took the
recommendations that we made to heart
and actually acted upon them we acquired
a small business called Jackthreads
which sort of served as the supply side
to the demand that we were creating
through our content and have since built
Jackthreads into the fastest growing
men's e-commerce business on the web my
name is Ben leer I'm the co-founder of
Thrillist media but Android was growing
so quickly we said we need to give this
a real shop you to build something truly
native and we need to work with the
folks at Android to figure out what
that's supposed to look like and we're
really happy we did since you redesigned
the jackets up we've found that 30% of
new signups through Android are actually
becoming daily active users which is an
engagement metric that's pretty
unparalleled and not only that but our
Android users are two times as likely to
sign up as any other platform we tend to
be developing Android first at this
point and so the two things that really
move the needle for us one is an ability
to a be test in real time what that does
is it lets us focus on engagement lets
us really get into the data and make
sure that the changes were making to the
app or the right ones the developer
console provides tools for testing that
you really can't get on any other
platform we can roll out a really cool
idea we have to part of our users see if
it works if it doesn't roll back if it
does go to everyone and it's really
allowed us to lead with Android and
design wholeheartedly
we're in 14 Internet
markets right now I think that there's a
big opportunity to leverage Google's
tools provide a better experience for
guys in those markets one of the biggest
pain points we see in apps is getting
users to enter their credit card
information having that already
available to our users is a service that
is completely unparalleled last year we
grew our Android sales by just short of
two thousand percent and over the past
three months we've increased sales by
just short of 500 percent so we're
showing really explosive growth there
and the numbers are not slowing down
[Music]